في هذه المدينه اكبر المدن الاسرائيليه
نتحدث عن هذا الشارع هو احد الشوارع
المركزيه في قلب تل ابيب مغلق بالكامل
امام حركه
المركبات الاف الاسرائيليين والمحتجين
يسيرون في هذه الشوارع بشكل
عشوائي يسيرون الى مناطق ومواقع مختلفه
للاحتجاج على قرار رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي قالت وزير الدفاع
يؤمنون الاعلام الاسرائيليه ولكن العديد
من اللافتات التي تصف نتنياهو
كذب وديكتاتور ومجرم وفاسد هذه اللافتات
التي رايناها خلال سيرنا الى هذا الموقع
يوم امس يوم السبت وصلت الاحتجاجات بحسب
منظمي هذه الاحتجاجات الى اكثر من 600 الف
مشارك في عده نقاط في داخل اسرائيل اليوم
لم يكن هناك اي خطه للخروج الى هذه
المظاهرات كانت هناك مظاهرات محدوده قباله
عده منازل لنواب ووزراء في الائتلاف
الحاكم ولكن ما ان اعلن نتنياهو عن اقاله
وزير الدفاع حتى خرج هؤلاء الالاف والان
رفعوا المطالب